la domanda iniziale che mi sono posto e
se l'organizzazione degli aiuti
umanitari ha in realtà condotto in linea
di massima e considerando le risorse che
sono investite negli aiuti umanitari ad
una mancata resilienza cioè ha creato
più effetti collaterali in realtà che il
beneficio che era atteso all'inizio e
volevo cominciare anche legandomi agli
interventi delle persone che mi hanno
preceduto offrendovi due parole la prima
parola è memoria e la seconda parola e
preconcetti o pregiudizio perché queste
due parole sono molto legate perché
soprattutto mi ricollego all'ultimo
intervento no di mohammed che ha parlato
per ultimo nel primo blocco una parte
della storia che abbiamo ascoltato e una
storia che in alcuni di noi e le nostre
famiglie potrebbe richiamare alla
memoria delle situazioni che i nostri
nonni bisnonni zii hanno dovuto
affrontare non più di qualche decennio
fa quando hanno deciso di migrare alla
ricerca di una vita migliore
chi di noi a queste storie deve avere
sicuramente sentito parlare
i timori delle paure delle difficoltà
sono sono sono andati via su un
transatlantico storie di viaggi no era
il primo blocco nere di viaggi che hanno
messo sicuramente alla prova elementi
fondamentali della sopravvivenza e
fornire il mangiare il bere la paura
dello sconosciuto e quindi confrontare
questo elemento di memoria anche vicina
per molti di noi con l'immaginario e la
narrativa attuale rispetto alle
migrazioni che stanno
riguardando l'europa così da vicino
perché prendiamo le cose che ci stanno
più vicine anche perché se il concetto
di resilienza concetto che si rifà alla
nostra capacità di assorbire uno shock
l'arrivo di migliaia di persone
sconosciute che magari non parlano la
nostra lingua che non sappiamo cosa
vengono a fare sicuramente una forma di
shock sociale importante e allora qual è
la nostra capacità attento come società
e di risposta teniamo presente
l'elemento della memoria la seconda
parola che volevo offrirvi e condividere
a questa riflessione il pregiudizio
perché molto spesso quando la memoria
corta e ci fa dimenticare situazioni
difficili anche per aiutarci a superare
quei momenti quelle sensazioni oppure
quelle forme magari anche di di senso di
umiliazione sociale personale la memoria
può essere allo stesso tempo la mancanza
di memoria può trasformarsi nella nella
causa nella fonte di un pregiudizio
rispetto a quello che sta accadendo
attorno ed e un po quello che accade che
a cui cerchiamo di affrontare un
dibattito relativo all'utilità
l'inutilità degli aiuti umanitari
in particolare a sostegno della capacità
delle persone di assorbire reagire a
situazioni difficili perché poi in
realtà la parola resilienza che adesso
va tanto di moda quindi la usiamo per i
materiali per la scienza per le società
per le persone la usiamo un po su tutto
no è una di quelle parole chiave che
adesso è la nipote probabilmente
dell'innovazione la figlia della
sostenibilità cioè di tutte quelle
parole che ogni tanto si sono buttate lì
vanno alla moda e perdono il significato
allora proviamo a ridare un significato
molto concreto che il significato legato
all'interesse degli individui ogni
individuo vittima di uno shock cerca
innanzitutto in se stesso
gli elementi
per superare questo shock e tornare a
una vita normale la cosa interessante
nell'ambito degli aiuti umanitari se
volete proprio questa tensione tra
l'aiutare l'individuo e l'andare a
intervenire in sistemi o in contesti di
cui magari fondamentalmente chi cerca di
aiutare chi porte agli aiuti non si
trova non trova adeguati non trovi
aggiusti non trova corrette
medici senza frontiere ha pubblicato uno
studio in cui sostiene che non sia la
responsabilità degli attori umanitari
aiutare le popolazioni ad imparare come
reagire in caso di catastrofe come
reagire in casi di shock perché hanno
sottolineato una correlazione in qualche
modo conflittuale fra aiutare
l'individuo che nel momento che segue
una catastrofe un terremoto una guerra
ha bisogno di soddisfare i propri i
propri bisogni più fondamentali mangiare
bere avere un tetto sopra la testa
eccetera ed aiutare quei contesti quei
governi quelle amministrazioni ma anche
quel mondo dell'associazionismo che vive
no un po dietro questo tipo di aiuti e
ne abbiamo avuto degli esempi nel nostro
paese con alcune delle degli scandali
nella nostra capitale no e quindi medici
senza frontiere si dice se per aiutare
l'individuo devo avere a che fare con
con quegli attori governativi non
governativi che sono probabilmente anche
alla causa di alcuni di questi sciocco
comunque che cercano di fare
sciacallaggio su questi shock perché
perché chiaramente non si può aiutare un
individuo su un corto periodo su un
breve periodo e attendersi che poi se
uno shock riviene quell'individuo da
solo sarà capace di reagire no allora
l'idea e se devo aiutare non solo
l'individuo aveva a che fare con gli
altri attori non sto facendo l'interesse
dell'individuo quindi voi mi dite che
sto aiutando un sistema una comunità un
paese a essere più resiliente cioè a
imparare come fare la prossima volta
a risolvere i propri problemi ad
assorbire lo shock
però allo stesso tempo una parte del mio
sforzo sta fallendo l'obiettivo perché
non sta aiutando gli individui questo
disco se estrapolato da contesti attuali
da contesti scusate specifici e portato
un po su scala diventa un discorso molto
problematico perché non è solamente una
domanda filosofica in quella domanda di
investimento dove mandiamo le nostre
risorse
cosa ne facciamo cosa ci spingerà a
decidere di investire le nostre risorse
in un'attività magari lontana dal nostro
paese piuttosto che investire nel nostro
sistema sociale solamente un senso
filantropico di aiutare chi è più
sfortunato di noi quindi poi entriamo in
un gioco di relativismo della sfortuna
no la realtà però è che è impossibile
non porsi queste domande del momento in
cui l'elemento della vulnerabilità o
comunque i fattori di vulnerabilità
stanno crescendo a livello mondiale in
maniera esponenziale ed allo stesso
tempo sta stanno portando una parte
della pressione di questi shock del
dell'impatto di queste crisi che siano
naturali o politiche alle nostre porte
per darvi un'idea l'anno scorso
l'organizzazione diciamo l'ufficio delle
nazioni unite per il coordinamento degli
affari umanitari che quindi anche la
responsabilità di cercare di
quantificare i bisogni di aiuti
umanitari ha richiesto aiuti per 80
milioni di persone in 37 paesi e questo
non comprende i paesi occidentali che
hanno i che investono le proprie risorse
quindi proviamo ad immaginare quando
portiamo a livello di scala
le vulnerabilità e il numero di
individui che sono toccati da queste
vulnerabilità che che responsabilità e
di fronte al quale responsabilità enorme
ci troviamo allora la risposta che se
cade dare quella di organizzare per lo
meno l'arrivo di aiuti a una gran parte
di quegli 80 milioni di individui in 37
paesi
e le teorie della resilienza ci dicono
che come gli aiuti non solo devono
aiutare con gli individui a mangiare
oggi ad avere un bagno ad andare a
scuola
dopodomani no per poter occupare in
maniera proficua il tempo dei ragazzi
eccetera ma ci dicono anche che con gli
aiuti devono lasciare un impatto nella
capacità di quelle stesse comunità che
al prossimo tornado dovranno rialzarsi
da sole quindi non avranno più bisogno
di un'iniezione di aiuto esterno
allora credo che uno degli elementi
fondamentali dell'inadeguatezza o della
percepita inadeguatezza degli aiuti
umanitari nella sharon e di capacità in
spone a cadere e rialzarsi da solo la
volta successiva è che ci si aspetta che
un paracetamolo permette all'individuo
di non prendere mai più la febbre
noi sappiamo invece benissimo che la
medicina palliativa quello che fa in
qualche modo minimizza il sintomo non
aiuta necessariamente a risolvere quello
che il problema è quindi una delle una
seconda domanda che mi sono posto nel
cercare di costruire il contenuto è ma
nel momento in cui cerchiamo di
esplorare questo lato oscuro della
resilienza attraverso l'inadeguatezza
degli aiuti umanitari
stiamo ponendo la domanda corretta nel
senso delle attese di rapporto causa
effetto tra l'investimento dell'aiuto
umanitario e la capacità poi di quella
comunità di cavarsela da solo alla volta
dopo se lo scopo dell'accompagnamento
alla resistenza è quello di creare una
capacità di adattamento e risposta
quindi in modo dinamico perché alcuni
dicono alla resilienza con un concetto
di elasticità ti riporta da dove sei
partito allora noi sappiamo benissimo
che nelle vite nella vita degli
individui così come in natura
ogni effetto shock lascia poi verdi un
impatto in larga parte permanente che
porta una trasformazione quindi non c'è
un equilibrio di ritorno alla posizione
iniziale per lo meno nel quando parliamo
di shock abbastanza importanti e quindi
se lo scopo di accompagnare la
resilienza è quello di favorire questa
capacità di assorbimento di un di un
trauma e di superamento di
trasformazione per andare avanti
probabilmente il ruolo di un palliativo
può essere quello semplicemente di
aiutare ad attutire il colpo non può
essere quello di tutti il colpo e di
stabilire già il nuovo corso di
avanzamento poi della vita di alcuni
individui e credo che questo sia
estremamente importante perché a che
fare anche un po con le aspettative
e ancora una volta con i pregiudizi che
si possono creare rispetto a delle
attese di investimento di aiuti che non
giustifica necessariamente
l'inefficienza nella gestione non
giustifica assolutamente non
necessariamente in efficienza della
gestione o comunque l'incapacità a volti
di arrivare dove ce ne sia più bisogno
però credo che e portati nel contesto
sempre continuando a usare la metafora
dell'elasticità ricordarsi che quanto
più noi tendiamo un elastico senza
permettere di in qualche modo di
attutire quella quella qualità che
l'elasticità tanto maggiore è il rischio
che alla fine questi così spezi anche il
migliore degli elastici in qualche modo
quindi credo che possiamo
tranquillamente ricordare attraverso la
nostra memoria ma anche attraverso le
storie più recenti che è possibile
superare degli shock ed adattarsi e
trasformare il proprio modo di essere è
più probabile che ci si riesca dopo
shock maggiori se si riceve in qualche
modo una
momento essi si è messi in condizione di
far leva sulle proprie forze e parliamo
di cose molto molto banali cioè il
giorno dopo che ti è crollata a casa se
non mangi e non bevi come puoi andare a
rimuovere tu stesso da solo con la tua
comunità le macerie
quindi non stiamo facendo alta filosofia
stiamo facendo
riflessioni veramente di pragmatismo
basilare nel cercare di di collegare
quello che si può fare per aiutare gli
individui a superare un momento di un
momento di difficoltà in realtà il lato
più oscuro della resilienza e il lato
legato al tentativo di accompagnamento
dei sistemi perché la prossima volta che
una catastrofe tocca un paese che oggi
non è stato capace di rispondere da solo
ci si aspetta che quel paese attraverso
i suoi sistemi l'amministrazione delle
risorse delle capacità la protezione
civile sia capace di rispondere da solo
quindi è importante pensare agli
investimenti nel senso della resilienza
individuale delle comunità e grandi
shock nel momento in cui di choc non ha
avuto o non stanno avendo luogo quindi
da qui l'importanza anche della
prevenzione perché come coloro di noi
che non può oscillato nel mondo degli
aiuti internazionali sanno c'è una forte
tensione tra il voler pianificare con
perfezione gli interventi e il dovere
invece atterrare in nepal con un livello
di distruzione massimo
e tutto quello che puoi fare è non
filosofeggiare ma buttarsi a capofitto e
dare una mano
e chiaro che è meglio che ci vada un
ingegnere rispetto a che ci vado una
persona di buon cuore buona volontà ma
da dove cominciare a mettere le mani e
quindi grazie a quei sistemi e poi
possibile aiutare l'individuo ad
adattarsi ea superare anche perché come
ci ricorda questa questa citazione
inesorabile nella vita adattarsi o
morire
questa è la citazione un po drammatica
se volete legata ai grandi shock
la buona notizia è che gli individui in
linea di massima hanno una grande
capacità di reazione e adattamento
pensiamo anche alle nostre a qui nei
dintorni io vengo da matera il terremoto
degli anni 80 degli spini ahmad tanti
tanti casi anche spesso d'inondazioni
quindi l'individuo e i gruppi di
individui se hanno una base minima su
cui poter far leva per reagire sono
naturalmente portati ad adattarsi a
reagire
la questione è che il resto della
comunità che attorno a quegli individui
che subiscono l'impatto di una crisi
parta dal presupposto di esplorare cosa
è possibile fare per fornire quella base
perché poi gli individui prendono in
conto loro stessi loro bisogni superino
da soli quel quel momento di difficoltà
e questo in realtà è la vera
conversazione sulla resilienza e per
portarla ai giorni attuali la questione
non è la domanda non è migranti si
migranti no perché tanto arrivano lo
stesso
la domanda è esattamente legata quale
l'investimento come comunità più larga
per dare una base a delle persone che in
gran parte hanno anche delle educazioni
abbastanza elevati se pensiamo ad alcuni
di gruppo alcuni gruppi di queste
persone stanno arrivando per far leva
sulla loro innata formati resilienza
perché se uno nel resilienza
intimi che attraversa il deserto e
arriva vivo tre anni dopo e ragazzi
la forma di resilienza quindi cosa
facciamo solidarmente perché quello che
oggi sta accadendo ad altri un giorno
magari potrà accadere a noi se siamo
consapevoli della memoria perché c'è già
successo per dare una spinta e una base
in quella direzione e quindi mi avvio
alla conclusione
lo scopo non deve essere quello nella
famosa metafora del pesce dell'insegnare
a pescare di la cito stata data come
input anche per l'intervento non è
assolutamente quello di mettere in piedi
uno stato sociale che crei una
dipendenza estrema ed allargare le
responsabilità dello stato sociale di un
paese a tutti coloro che ne varcano le
soglie o a tutti coloro che non vorremmo
che varcassero le soglie la
responsabilità di una forma di aiuti
qualunque essa sia esattamente fornire
il perno perché gli individui facciano
leva leva di una caratteristica innata
ecco nel caso degli aiuti umanitari
sicuramente ci sono degli effetti
collaterali come in ogni medicina a
volte sono effetti di dipendenza e
quindi degli effetti collaterali sugli
individui stessi ma a volte sono sono
effetti negativi sui sistemi subisce
quegli aiuti che la corruzione
l'arricchimento illecito non sono mica
studiati a tavolino con con i migranti
con i rifugiati con chi ha bisogno
quindi gli effetti collaterali sono di
varia natura come al solito in una forma
evolutiva e non di equilibrio stabile
perché questo è un elemento fondamentale
a tenere a mente ogni volta che si cerca
di trovare la soluzione a un problema
bisogna porsi in maniera dinamica non di
ritorno al passato ma divisione verso il
futuro
e chiaro che non sta a chi gestisce
mette in piedi quegli aiuti del bisogno
nel primo momento mastacchi
a quello quel quella distanza per
guardare al medio e lungo termine di
finire come rispondere agli effetti
collaterali per permettere alla
determinazione di averla vinta sulla
paura
vi ringrazio